[Music]
24 seconds of Lego logos 24 seconds of
Legos this is a great opening shop no
doubt but those are large Lego sheets
that make up the lava so there shouldn't
be any way to make bubbles according to
this movie's rules he is coming
cover your butt cover the wat dam
Vitruvius couldn't you give the guards
an actual warning before they get
smashed to pieces by the business
onslaught your robots are no match for a
masterbuilder this is right he's a
master builder that should have no
problem taking on a few peon robots like
these but all he does is summon up a
flock of seagulls to attack them and is
immediately shot nothing's gonna stop me
now wait there was a prophecy
why doesn't business just kill but
Rubeus right now especially after he's
already ordered the robots to destroy
him also while this movie takes great
pains and laughing at movie prophecies
the fake prophecy ends up being true so
it's kind of like all the prophecies in
movies ever only with more laughing
especially one with face I'm tempted to
say that's racist but it's really the
opposite almost everyone in this movie
has a face of yellow so this detail has
no business being in this prophecy that
was a great inspiring legend that you
made up actually Lord business is
correct but we're still gonna watch an
entire movie pretending he was wrong
only to learn he was correct eight and a
half ten years later you're telling me
it took that long for Lord business to
weaponize the crackle the level of
detail in this movie is awesome but how
the hell does Emmett ride that bike over
there it's only got one Lego stud for a
seat which means only half of his ass
will fit and he'll be all upside it am i
thinking too much about the
practicalities of transportation in an
animated toy movie
you bet I am good morning doorway
morning MA even a chipper frequent hello
person wouldn't say hello to their
bedroom doorway everyday I mean come on
that doorway and not the door itself why
does this doorway were in a good morning
before the three dozen other inanimate
objects in this room everything about
this poster screams hockey except the
word sport
why is everything this far bin Lego
sighs but suddenly this razor and
toothbrush or ginormous it M it
typically showers with the curtain
opened like this his entire apartment
should be a sea of little round blue one
pieces under what scenario does Emmett
think that any of these outfits have
anything to do with going to work today
it's not like it's his first day of work
or he's that stupid
hi I'm cinemasins and I take joyful
moments and try them come up jeez what
an asshole I am also this funny costume
montage reveals that Emmett either
has a flex like obsession with disguise
or he's previously had careers as a
surgeon and Archer a magician a clown
and Godzilla lego movie steals the Alma
ball show from idiocracy I can get the
irony of everything is awesome while
seeing a 16 Lane interstate piled with
cars and confusing road signs but one
side of this should be relatively free
of cars correct ones going into town the
other is going out of town
also while these are super confusing at
least the right side has road signs but
the left side apparently doesn't get any
signs every single car in this row park
at the same time how is there nobody
parked already this isn't so much
parallel parking as it is impossible
synchronized parallel parking I know
these signs are basically a
representation of Pappa Farrell's rules
for his kid but no marching bands was
that necessary for an eight-year-old or
at all
[Music]
you've been at work for five hours and
it's already dark the hell kind of book
place do you live anyway also five hours
later and they're already calling it a
day but they just got there and started
singing damn and it's work schedule is
badass in the waning hours of the work
day the instructions tell the Lego
workers to create an elaborate ballet of
construction equipment oh who knew LEGO
pieces could be linked to the clown or
even electrified well I'm gonna have to
report
[Music]
I'll take two sins off for the Solaris
nests but then add one back for
wyldstyle taking off her mask for any
reason during this mission I don't mind
this kid imagining all this happening
but just how deep to his dad's Lego
buildings go anyway considering that we
later learn emit as a fraud and even the
prophecy is a fraud this crazy magic
flashback vision thing Emmet hands when
first touching the piece of resistance
seems kind of stupid right the piece of
resistance
animated Liam Neeson character isn't
killing anyone in the scene just three
days before president of business is
going to use the croco to end the world
president business is going to end the
war bad cop goes all Hagrid on our asses
and says more than he should which
allows our hero to kick-start the plot
you see when you say the other guy I go
characters go to great lengths to
describe how aggressively average and
inconsequential Emmet is also this
interview footage of construction
workers was expertly shot and edited for
maximum and that humiliation you know
he's just sort of also bad cops video
investigation somehow led him to the
coffee shop to talk to the barista it's
at this point I wonder how did Emmet get
the piece of resistance glued to his
back the only person in this universe
with the kragle is lowered business yeah
sure we know the kid Finn did this in
the real world but glue is supposed to
be bad remember wyldstyle is such a
lethal assassin here makes me wonder why
they need it doesn't heroes and a plan
at the end of this movie instead of just
sending in wild style and letting her go
all beserker and the enemy also with
wild style is this awesome at fighting
then why did she care that Emmet saw her
earlier couldn't she have just run down
to get the piece of resistance and
whooshed on out of there and how did
Emmett make his way up to ground level
without wyldstyle noticing and just
taking the piece while he's passed out I
realize we're sending a kid's
imagination here but this is some simple
imagination this one hack somehow
releases Emmitt from both shackles cut
it off on them now or whatever you can
good cops should be reserved to
interrogations right otherwise he's just
giving his crew mixed messages but
didn't Vitruvius get kicked off the
cliff into the lava the beginning of
this movie are you telling me he had a
Gandalf like experience where he fell to
his death but became Vitruvius the white
for virtually no reason at all the Attic
latter falls down to give em at a ramp
why didn't you just do that in the first
place where are we
titles on screen responding to an in
movie characters question for the
viewing audience is benefit you ruined
the prophecy
hang on wyldstyle I'd say if the
prophecy allowed Emmitt to collect the
piece of resistance it's the prophecy
that's up here also you're the one that
maybe you're not the one but you'll
totally be the one by the end of the
movie cliche and we search for the piece
of resistance the only thing that can
stop the kragle they're telling me the
original cap to the super glue is the
only thing and all the varied Lego
kingdoms that can cover and stop the
flow of super glue from the superglue
container I say you assholes are trying
hard enough
who's going to use the kragle to end the
world in three days yeah but it's only
Taco Tuesday in bricksburg panels Lord
business gonna gather everyone for
destruction in the other worlds also why
if you hadn't read the script with
something as scrumptious as Taco Tuesday
tip off your spidey senses this entire
movie is made M it out to be so common
in a sea of commonality that nobody
remembers it but physically everyone's
got a thing like different facial hair
or markings different hair altogether so
basically this is the Star Trek's
feature or the Planet of the Apes kolima
I won't test it on you I'll do it on
your parents Lord business imports bad
cops parents entire house instead of
just abducting the two of them and
crackling them to a random Lego piece
removing good cops facial features
removes the entire good cop personality
from this guy somehow also though as an
aside is lego sex the most basic thing
ever or what hey my rounded peg would
seem to fit in year-round at home come
let us attach and unattach ourselves
together repeatedly for a few minutes
damn this kid even managed to imagine a
hooker in the saloon this kid's like
eight right eat me upstairs in ten
seconds this is hilarious but why would
the octant title card company make
silent title cards for what is the
protagonists adventure more importantly
why make title cards for anything your
mind is already so prodigiously empty
that there is nothing in it to clear
away in the first place is this the
silliest movie Morgan Freeman's ever
appeared in no he was also in Ted too
now you see
me too and Dolphin Tale - I know a crazy
right still true prophecy chosed you in
it
we know that wizard Vitruvius is making
this up as he goes along but why the
certainty about Emmett's usefulness
can't he just take the piece of
resistance and with the help of all the
other remaining master-builders can't
the kragle himself all you have to do is
to believe all you have to do is believe
please shame
draw a cowboy hat on him but wait don't
have the people in the saloon have a
cowboy hat and isn't the point that
everyone has the same face so common
hats wouldn't make a difference after
hundreds of shots by his minions at the
hang-glider bad cop takes them out with
one shot these robot cops should just be
stormtrooper figures rather than be
propelled forward after hitting this
train the heroes conveniently goes
straight up and conveniently land on top
of the convenient train that is
convenient Oh No did bad cop actually
get on these train tracks knowing that
the heroes would eventually jump on this
train and what kind of xxx state of the
union is this anyway again why not do
this in the first place rest in pieces
way to make this yet another Batman
scene involving Ra's al Ghul and a
speeding train well they threw and
Lucius Fox somehow to Batman when the
does Emmet know who Batman is
he lives in bricksburg remember a place
where everything is generic and the only
thing on the TV is where are my pants
you think president business is gonna
allow a vigilante superhero to be shown
on public media so if this universe is
based on the playset that the kid is
using in the real world where is cloud
cuckoo-land big and complicated enough
that the dad would have noticed and it's
obviously that jacent to one of the
traditional sets no bushes moustaches I
understand the rest but why the war on
moustaches some of that painted right on
their face and they can't help it of
course we saw Emmett shave his face a
while back so what do I know what's real
the special will now give an eloquent
speech the fact that anybody who knows
Emmett at this point thinks this will go
well Church that shark is out of water
that doesn't compute at all
why implement a shark defense system on
the infinity of floor miles above sea
level and you know see and strange
dangerous relics that entrap snap and
zap
how are those used against you again
every single part of this story shows
you getting your asses kicked by all the
dangerous stuff in the tower but here
the relics are just sitting on their
pedestals being used by nobody large
idea have
that'd be better than the ideas of 100
of our fallen masterbuilder brothers
well Emmett has the piece of resistance
right something you didn't have when you
broke into Lord business's tower on the
last attempt Jesus why did they even try
that time without the single most
important relic they needed and an inn
company had to ride a Rainbow Bridge up
to cloud cuckoo-land
but this pirate drops out of it into the
water with no sign of any kind of
rainbow bridge in sight is the Rainbow
Bridge temporary or does the movie just
not get about cloud cuckoo rules well at
least it can't get any worse every time
a movie character says this an angel
gets its wings ripped off by a god-sized
pair of pliers huge ass blinking
tracking device goes unnoticed by
everyone in this entire movie until now
because of course it does
dang it
Wow in a total dick move Wonder Woman
must have perked her jet literally on
top of the Batmobile I guess Lego
Superman doesn't have the power to just
end this entire attack by bad cop right
now ready for that hilarious moment
interrupted by logic it was a basketball
they didn't have to be ready for it it's
been harmless you were part of a group
that was just giving em it for being
useless and then you go and do this if
you let go Shaq you're a fraud you're no
more master builder than em it is it's
win to stuff like this stop Superman
isn't this the type of thing that stops
Hulk and dream catchers in case we take
a nap Morgan Freeman dream catcher
references forcibly inserted into the
tubes of this lego movie you must
embrace what is special about you
but that's nothing he's an instructions
following loser that's the entire point
of the movie actually that even and
nobody's ideas are worthwhile but here
you suggest he's still special in some
way despite numerous moments proving he
is not and you knowing you made the
whole thing up in the first place in
Lego world clowns can get so fire damage
they crash into the sea which sort of
makes them not clouds but whatever
science doesn't exist in this movie it's
not like I need dr. Tyson's help here I
got this one doc like Wonder Woman
couldn't take out all these fools in her
own and let's not forget we're in this
situation because Superman god damned
Superman was defeated by bubblegum so
wait no every time waters been shown in
this movie it has been flat sheets or
little one pieces of blue Legos so them
traveling through this sea of actual
water is a freaking lie I don't care if
it's a little kids imagination play by
our rules movie then after a few leaks
the fucking thing explodes explodes it
loaded instead of sinking holes in a sub
caused an explosion that just happened
survivors sensors can see into the water
but literally can't see through a
double-decker couch how do they get
Superman out of the gum pile whoever and
whatever touched it should have also
been stuck like Green Lantern and it's
much-maligned double decker couch
actually saves the day but how did these
assholes fit in the seat cushions this
isn't the Millennium Falcon's secret
compartments here you have to do some
very simple things with the scale of the
human beings in this world to make this
work
pirate Lego Lex machina also pirate guy
goes on to explain he came back because
he watched Lord businesses forces
totally overlook the double-decker couch
okay Thor whatever but you were leaving
you said why were you even still around
to keep an eye on a floating couch you
like left but actually hid behind a rock
and spied on everything I guess the
little detail of a true B is drinking
from the couch cup here is just so
goddamn hilarious to me that I must
remove the sin it's follow the
instructions and it says this and it
definitely sounds brilliant
but then their plan ultimately involves
very little instruction following and a
metric asked ton of improvisation I mean
by follow the instructions M it mostly
means draw up a plan in advance which is
actually a totally different thing
somebody get me some markers some
construction paper wait aren't they
supposed to be avoiding any adhesives
yeah but according to your precious
instructions he made that with markers
construction paper and glitter glue
really apparently Emmett's planned
spaceship that looks like president
businesses spaceships calls for a
hyperdrive they got to this point in the
Lego world by train horseback and a
floating double-decker couch so a
hyperdrive is not needed to get to
president businesses tower but the movie
wanted to shoehorn in a Star Wars moment
and so we get this Batman is about to
jump on the Millennium Falcon here which
as you see includes Lando Calrissian
but because Lando is actually voiced by
Billy Dee Williams that also includes
Harvey Dent until Tommy Lee Jones
replaces him mid-flight what Han and
everybody be doing and yet another
asteroid with yet another space slug I
demand answers for this parody that is
both hilarious and entertaining but
sinful also is the kid flashing back
like the movie is right now does his
mind work like a family Guy episode step
Benny and metal beard who sneak their
way into the master control room metal
beard the largest noisiest loudest
motherfucker on your team and you sent
him on the sneak mission hot jesus this
plan is really stupid
metal beard is suddenly a goddamn
transformer and can turn into an object
one-tenth his size like a copy machine
this is all new information presented as
fact
not only is the first thought robot
soldiers have when they see
copier to photocopy their asses but
metal beer transformed into a functional
copy machine really that was awesome
first law of the sea one of the rules
has never released a Kraken and if
you're one of others maybe you take that
one step further and never again release
a Clash of the Titans
step 5 but Rubeus will provide lookout
make sure we're not being followed okay
this is a funny moment but everything
else about Emmett's plan actually makes
sense so why through in this useless job
four blind old RIT I move that we freeze
the universe can I get a second on that
why the balls does Lord business need
board approval to freeze the universe
it's either an evil secret plan or
something that would have been planned
for months not a rubber-stamp the day
before it happens what do you mean you
have always been a robot despite large
reams of up being robots Emmett and
wyldstyle managed to escape this
situation I just realized this is the
first of two blockbusters where Chris
Pratt's character gets himself out of a
jam with a comical music dance number
and now I feel like there almost has to
be a Jurassic world deleted scene of him
in the Raptor Bros popping and locking
that night in the city one you thought I
was the special damn this kid's
imagination sure has gotten dramatic all
of a sudden this is a tremendously
complex fantasy hey what are you two
losers talking about did the plan call
for Batman to be here right now or is he
just being Batman doing whatever he
wants how might this screw up Emmett's
plan does Batman care this business
leads a coordinated attack on all the
heroes at the same time leading us to
believe he had snipped out the plot and
was ready for it
but if it hadn't paused for this line
everything would have been different the
next thing we minutes of this movie is
solely because the hero and villain both
have a thing for dramatic timing the
prophecy I made it up Vitruvius tells
Emmet this when he's about to die rather
than days ago but honestly the real bull
fears that this prophecy was so specific
and everything about it except Emmet
turns out to be true except the Emmet
part even turns out to be true kind of
in that Kung Fu Panda way what I'm about
to tell you will change the course of
history the electric shocker 100
Mississippi no problem villains it's a
needlessly long timer for people getting
killed and doesn't even bother to stay
around to witness it and terminate
everyone okay so Papa Pharoah wants to
glue everything that already exists in
place and that's explained but why would
he terminate all the master-builders
that are providing instructions for the
stuff that's still being built like
there are skyscrapers in bricksburg that
are still under construction right
and ghost Vitruvius the effects in
conceit of this movie are brilliant
taking Legos and making them move on
their own in their own little universe
so why are we getting these wink wink
moments now like 70% into the movie
who wants a taco half the happy
responders to this question are in
sombreros that's racist
does anyone have any ideas I do let's
get Superman to save the day
Benny send this out to everyone in the
universe I know most of the droid
I mean robot arming is with business
right now but there should be someone
left behind in the elephants right at
least the ones that were previously
directing and watching this show and he
was just like all of you a face in the
crowd the speech is awesome but where
the hell did she get all this backstory
footage of Emmet to run under this
emergency broadcast some of this
violates the First Amendment I think I
mean this here says security footage but
it's emitted his own apartment does this
society film every residents personal
actions in their apartments I used to
think they follow us funny that they got
the town crier to read this news but
this is being shown concurrent with
wyldstyle speech so how are they getting
this news in real time
wait there's a security footage up the
goddamn double-decker couch escape okay
now who filmed this where is camera
here's more security cam footage to the
feels like just previous movie scene
footage degraded to look like security
footage I mean the bad guys had this on
camera you never would have gotten away
with it right the kragle hoses politely
pause their destruction of this town so
its residents can get properly inspired
the scene progression made me smile so
hard my face nearly broke off once and
removed this another fish so this is
where the kids imagination diverts from
the Rubies story and it's unclear how
those two timelines interact obviously
the kid doesn't know that Emmet
sacrificed himself for his friends
because he doesn't know he could move
around in the real world which means
that either explanation of how this
movie movies is flawed this is a
disaster it's hard to believe that Vince
Duffy dad actually bought Legos in order
to build his model Empire permanently oh
dude why don't you go ahead and use the
glue when you so obviously meant to use
it for your model dad ensures the
cancellation of one of his avatars
favorite shows dad business does the
squirt some of the medicine out before
giving the shot cliche with the
container of superglue okay the
micromanagers have been gluing things in
the Lego world while Dad business was
gluing them now however dad business is
walking away from the table to tend to
Emmet so why are the micromanagers
closing in on a robot pirate ascending
is neat and clever but it actually
raises way more questions than it
answers
the piece of resistance can still save
them now you saw that dozens of other
cry angles in the drawer dummy and it is
suddenly a masterbuilder because reasons
you see this is what I'm talking about
is the kid actually building this mech
suit for Emmet right now while his dad
is looking right at the city also the
micromanagers have been shown to be
dad's hands so the kid must literally be
slapping at his father's fingers Yuna
Kitty's negativity power is unleashed
man while I'd love to remove sins for
being awesome it took until this one
moment for her anger to finally come out
nothing before this did the trick only
seeing the thought to be dead Emmet in
the construction transformer being
attacked I guess if Emmet can hear
everyone right now they all somehow have
those magic Avengers earpieces
I guess you're expecting me to remove a
bunch of sins here at the end because we
learned most of this movie is happening
in this kid's imagination yeah while I'm
touched by the Will Ferrell ending and
it still moves all by himself in this
climactic scene suggesting he's actually
real so I'm gonna take off 20 sins for
this movie's raw heart and then cap it
they're assuming at least 75% of what I
saw in this movie was at least
potentially real Finn did you make all
of this suddenly this father thinks what
his son did is remarkable even though
just a couple minutes ago everything he
did was terrible I'd like to recap that
this is all because Emmet is a toy with
real human feelings who got Finn's
attention by falling off his dad's desk
who then gave him the piece of
resistance
Emmet suddenly turned into neo unikitty
suddenly turned into the Tasmanian devil
of killing things and now the dad not
knowing any of those things is like cool
shit son let's bond over this
what's the kragle here what's really
gonna bake dad's noodle is that there's
a king Lego figure that looks exactly
like him the prophecy is made up but
it's also true how fortuitous yeah but
even when they douse this universe in
mineral spirits there's no cooking wave
and get dudes pants off now
I have no idea to this day what those
two Italian ladies were singing about
truth is I don't want to know find a
black light place to look like a Jackson
Pollock painting this is even more
painful than it looks
if you don't I will look for you I will
find you and I will kill you
my boy
you
maybe instead of standing in line for
high-priced coffee beverages and it
should sign up for nature box because
then whether he goes on a crazy
adventure to save the universe or merely
has a normal workday at the construction
site he'd be set with snacks that are
delicious and good for him and I'm like
recapping the kragle signing up for
nature box is easy all you have to do is
go to nature box Commons and because
you're awesome they'll even give you 50%
off your first order in didya maybe you
like sweets maybe like salty snacks or
spicy stuff nature box has you covered
with a massive roster of snacks with new
snacks being added all the time
is that true it has to be and if you
don't like one they'll replace it for
free
that's like zero dollars save money on
your first order
get replacement snacks for ones you
don't like where's the risk just like
Emmet you are special and special people
deserve special snacks it's your destiny
so what are you waiting for power your
fruits pet to nature box calm and get
started snacking healthy today